actualizamos la información económica en
directo América con Daniela Blandón
Daniela nuevamente el saludo para
ustedes Hola Ángela muy buenos días
vamos a tener un enfoque distinto en
esta en esta en esta etapa de su
reportaje del día de hoy los ministros
de finanzas de la Unión Europea se
reunieron en Bruselas ya lo hicieron un
primer encuentro de los ministros de
finanzas pero de los 19 países de la
zona Euro el turno Este martes entonces
fue para todo el grupo de los 27 nuestra
corresponsable Esther Herrera nos envió
el siguiente reporte sobre las
conclusiones de la reunión en la que hay
que decir Estados Unidos fue
protagonista
todo el mundo daba por hecho que con la
marcha de Donald Trump de la Casa Blanca
las relaciones comerciales entre
Bruselas y Washington iban a ser un
remanso de paz pero lo cierto Es que las
fricciones Aún existen los ministros de
finanzas de la Unión Europea han
mostrado su enorme preocupación
especialmente por la ley de reducción de
la inflación anunciada recientemente por
la Casa Blanca una norma que activa con
ayudas Fiscales y también con ayudas
millonarias la economía estadounidense y
que implica por ejemplo también la ayuda
fiscal por la compra de automóviles
eléctricos fabricados en Estados Unidos
para Bruselas esto implica una
contravención de las normas comerciales
internacionales de momento Bruselas y
Washington han creado una comisión de
trabajo un grupo de trabajo para poder
abordar las preocupaciones y limar estas
asperezas y poder encontrar una solución
pero países como Francia han mostrado su
enorme preocupación y de hecho han dicho
que la comisión europea debería ir más
allá y llevar el caso ante la
Organización Mundial del Comercio la
cuestión es si es idóneo llevar a un
socio como Estados Unidos en plena
Guerra de Ucrania ante la Organización
Mundial del Comercio de momento Bruselas
insiste en que quiere encontrar una
solución negociada de hecho así se ha
mostrado dispuesta a poder negociar con
sus socios estadounidense y una de las
soluciones podría ser por ejemplo que
los automóviles europeos también estén
exentos de esta Norma igual que lo están
ya los automóviles de México y Canadá
después de ese reporte de Esther Herrera
hacemos un cambio de tema con la otra
gran noticia del día la economía
protagonista en las elecciones de medio
término en Estados Unidos si Ángela Pues
el balance de la economía estadounidense
en este momento es un conjunto de
Señales mixtas tanto para el mercado
como para los tomadores de decisiones
Como por ejemplo la reserva Federal es
un hecho que la inflación está en su
mayor nivel en cuatro décadas y en un
momento del año casi llega a tocar los
dos dígitos por eso el Banco Central ha
venido incrementando agresivamente su
tasa de interés para desacelentar
desalentar el consumo y también guiar
los precios a la baja pero también tiene
datos laborales muy sólidos son
desempleo del 3,7% esto es un poco por
encima de lo que dejó el ex presidente
Donald Trump en general se espera que la
economía crezca lentamente este año
después del susto de mitad de año de que
pudiera entrar en recesión los
republicanos precisamente han hecho de
la economía su caballo de batalla en la
campaña
si piensas en los problemas que
enfrentamos como país ves la inflación
en su nivel más alto en 40 años ves la
frontera abierta ves los problemas
energéticos que tenemos
todos esos problemas no se
materializaron de la nada todos fueron
problemas que han sido creados por las
propias políticas de bailén él está
causando esto con los préstamos de
billones de dólares que desencadenaron
la inflación
qué dicen entre tanto los demócratas el
presidente de Joe biden que no ha salido
referirse directamente a la inflación en
sus discursos de campaña porque no le
conviene no es algo de lo que deba
sentirse orgulloso si ha defendido sus
políticas para contenerla
Por cierto la invasión de Ucrania por
parte de Putin hizo que los precios de
la gasolina se dispararan en todo el
mundo pero debido a las medidas que
hemos tomado están bajando en esto tiene
razón efecto el precio del galón de
gasolina regular en promedio está hoy un
poco más de 3,7 dólares cuando en su
momento llegaron a alcanzar un récord
histórico de más de 5 dólares por galón
sin embargo Si siguen históricamente
altos estos precios de la gasolina y
bueno para el cierre de Daniela por
favor Le pido Los indicadores de la
jornada todos los mercados hoy desde
luego tiene la mirada puesta sobre las
elecciones de medio término en Estados
Unidos porque de ellas depende el
trámite de la agenda de Joe biden para
los próximos dos años
Wall Street está pendiente de la
apertura en unos minutos mientras que
las bolsas europeas operan mixtas con
leves variaciones las que suben lo hacen
impulsadas por algunos inversionistas
que están esperanzados en que la reserva
Federal tenga un tono un poco más
moderado en el alza de tasas los
mercados asiáticos cerraron mixtos los
tienen la esperanza de que china pueda
relajar sus estrictas medidas de
confinamiento por el covid 19 que han
arrastrado las bolsas en los últimos
días y ya mañana veremos cómo quedan los
indicadores después de estas elecciones
Daniela gracias a ustedes y vamos ahora
en directo a París